[Music]
this dude actually escaped jail because
of Kovan 19 and the reason why that
connects is because when like he
actually took another inmates identity
wore a face mask and that's how like
they weren't able to see that it was a
completely different guy and he also had
tattoos on his face but he wore a face
mask and he just strolled right up did
he ride a motorcycle on the way out
would you guys ever ride a motorcycle
you guys don't seem like the motorcycle
types to me no it's not my style I just
wear for the looks I wanted if I want to
look cool today you guys look really
safe to contour your face right your
cheeks in fact make the poofier it makes
a weak water I want a stronger jawbone
what do you do if someone started
coughing near you guys what oh you do
have now you're saying I think his chin
is blocked to look up oh you have the
filter you ready have one there
maybe maybe to be extra safe we should
go hungry - yeah we should ride like you
can get sick through your eyes that's
the safest way to ride damn I feel like
I like the pressure of that helmet is
like I don't know I feel I feel the
pressure in my head by watching the
squeezes the coalbed out every if you
went to the grocery store and you have
that would you just like so you're gonna
have a lemon or something really quick
it should be stapled on if it's like
something really quick yeah Wow your
hair stayed that way great hair yeah
that's crazy
I know your hair like did you do it or
does it you wake up like my hair gets
better if I wear a hat or something
so naturally I guess yeah so like not
curly hair if my hair is really messy in
the morning I throw on a hat for like a
few hours and then I'll take it off and
then it looks better
it's cleaner cuz if I wore a helmet my
hair is messed up like this pile is like
that yeah
I like that like this damn you have so
much volume dude
[Applause]
oh my gloves I gotta get my gloves - OH
only got a jacket and I got my
motorcycle jeans and my booth why just
with style anyway we're talking about
how this dude got out of jail for free
okay so this is the guy that took this
guy's identity yeah this guy was in jail
because he tried to escape
and he also got arrested because he beat
up an officer out there worse than
different orders yeah he didn't good you
didn't go to jail because you try to
escape jail no listen he went to jail
because he beat up some officers then
when he got out of jail he was on bail
and he had a possession of a weapon so
then when they tried to arrest him he
tried to escape so then he got arrested
and he got her like an escape charge for
that but then now he's in jail he has
like a fifty thousand dollar bond on him
you just seem like some cop saw him in
the street you're going to go to jail go
to jail batboy dude here he got he went
to jail because of a drug charge and so
he was due for parole so then this dude
offered this dude there's different
reports one of them says $500 another
one says a thousand but anyway he
offered him money to take his identity
and so like I said he had him at like he
had the mask on and that's when like
when they called this dude's name he
stepped forward and so he just signed
like paperwork
oh they also switched the jumpsuit call
yeah like thank your colors I don't know
but yeah so then that's how he was able
to escape so then once he left this hole
popped up and he was like hey
do you guys call my name I would I fell
asleep like I didn't hear you guys call
my name and there were like the [ __ ] you
you're not supposed to be here he's
supposed to be gone so then that's when
they realized oh [ __ ] we let this guy
out with you see like he has like face
tats and he doesn't that's right oh yeah
so then he was he was on the loose but
now they've reported he has been cut off
now they're both in trouble when they're
releasing the inmates it they're not
like hey think of me masking quick let's
live in your face I feel now they will
maybe everyone's scared of getting sick
so they're like keep it on stay over
there by like golf or something the ID
me and I'm wearing like a beanie or like
a mask they just like kind of like try
to make up they try to match the eye but
they don't because they can't tell you
to take it off yeah cuz you just feel
like I don't feel safe doing that it was
funny um Casey went to the bank
yesterday or two days ago and then he
forgot his mask he was like on his way
out but I'll say hey did you get your
mask he's like oh yeah I forgot he was
like this feels [ __ ] wrong I'm
getting a face mask to go to the bank
like and I was like that's just the new
norm no but he's like this feels like
I'm gonna get arrest it or something go
to the bank with a gun like this and a
[ __ ] face mask and you're like man so
weird
honey did you bring that gun to you
feels so wrong I'm you know how [ __ ]
weird that is is like it's almost closer
to reality because I feel like if you're
Chinese and you in this climbing you
might just have to walk around with a
gun now yeah so you walk around with a
gun and a face mask and then the robbers
walk around with nothing yeah they're
the ones without a gun in a face mask
give me all your money or what are you
gonna do cough I don't have a face mask
on they're like oh [ __ ] yeah give them
all the money yep did you guys see those
reports of inmates trying to
purposefully get the virus
yeah
Crona party they're sharing a mask too I
feel like they're well it's like almost
like you know when like in jail people
like passing a shank around or whatever
or like drugs around same thing like
there go like this then they pass it
around and everyone's trying to catch
corn and try to get out so how do I know
Korona because the water bottle that
they were sharing was hot water so they
were trying to like spike their their
temperature because the nurse was coming
and to check their temperature damn well
so if they if they're confirmed for
corona they just live better or like
hospitals are nicer than and then they
could probably escape so they don't get
out of jail cuz I heard a lot of people
getting released early it's not really
catching this early but like some people
are like other criminals that still
needed me and other just say [ __ ] it we
haven't here because like I think they
try and release nonviolent offense
offenders but it's not like oh you're
sick get out of here they release I'm
like molesters recently and yes
it was some hardcore scene hunting
Tanners yeah three of them Joe Rogan and
a lot of people were like posting
pictures of all these [ __ ] sex
offenders that got released and then
they committed the crime again like you
know the girl everyone had pictures mug
shots with like like this and we're like
one was dangling off like one ear like
that he looked like he got beat the [ __ ]
up and sure that one is practice sexual
assistance ooh I know right he has a
face mask and he's out here but Leslie
but he's still not [ __ ] abiding by
the [ __ ] rule I'm safe guys I know
it's some crazy [ __ ] to abide by the
mask rule but not by the sexual the mask
rule
it was probably off because of the mug
shot but the funny thing is they're
abiding by this mask another way yeah
the [ __ ] is wrong with them and then who
are they molesting because isn't
everyone at home that's where they're
finding them I mean if there's that yeah
I didn't read into like what they're
doing but they said that these guys they
just had a huge like [ __ ] like 9 or
10 dudes that it was like yeah because
they were released early cuz of all this
[ __ ]
and yeah you know and I we have a cop
friend on she was telling us she was
just ranting dude but she was saying
it's really [ __ ] up because of the
whole kovat thing if you commit like
like small crimes they are not even
trying to process them anymore cuz
they're trying to keep everything pretty
contained so they're just like [ __ ] man
we don't have room for this and we're
not trying to risk anything so we're
just gonna let you go and then they go
and they commit the crimes like you know
there's more about like they're
arresting uh people that like open up a
business again uh-huh I think they're
citing them but now that part yeah now
the cops are like just way overworked
because we have another cop neighbor
that works kind of the hood and so what
he's saying is you know like because of
social distance in quarantine you more
pandemics criminals don't just go that's
all shelter in you know it's the crime
is still the same so not only do you
have the crime now you have the like the
tattletales in the neighborhood that are
calling people all my neighbors not
wearing his mask but my neighbors not
doing that so so now that those extra
calls in addition to those that are the
Karen's yeah yeah other Karen calls and
then you have a spiking Karen claws and
then you also have a spike in the people
that are illegally open businesses so
it's it's like three times the amount of
police work when the police themselves
are trying to quarantine themselves and
figure out like a good shift schedule so
it's just [ __ ] like chaos right
because one of the neighborhoods he
patrols is like a Crips neighborhood and
he's like the one gives a [ __ ] about
social distancing my math like you drive
through is normal like they're not like
people on six feet apart like people are
still what about their blue bandanas
they don't just pull it up over their
face right that this would be the time
there yeah this would be the time when
gang banging is okay one tick tock
Rather's lady was in the grocery store
yeah
let me read one just go along with it
like she was like did you throw your
bees officially yeah yeah
you know what this sounds like it sounds
like it's a time for super JK we need to
assemble together and we need to be we
need to do what the cops can't do yeah
this about you guys yeah you could be
the incident man one one will be like
9:00 to 2:00 10:00 to 2:00 10:00 to look
at the kind of cuts one extra month
number though one zero two two all right
huh what did the kind of crimes worse
though oh dude we could go we don't even
have to follow the law because actual
sworn officer we're committing the crime
yeah what are we doing then was Batman
everyone loves Batman but Batman was a
[ __ ] criminal dude yeah I mean you
just shoot people yeah people he didn't
kill things but he doesn't follow the
law that's I mean he should have cuz if
he did then the Joker would have keep
[ __ ] with them you don't mean like
it's like this guy's BAM it's kind of
stupid he has all this he doesn't kill
these [ __ ] they keep [ __ ] the city
up for so many episodes that [ __ ] would
have been done and then they recur with
the crime right how DW lives are lost
because make sure he has a job as a
vigilante well that to me sounds like a
the pharmaceutical company that keeps
people sick Oh Batman is being a
terrorist in that sense but what the
super JK would do is we'll just we'll
just start shooting people mmm bigger
deadpool fan huh guys like stop selling
stop stealing gum you [ __ ] criminal
you're gonna do it again yeah
[Music]
[Music]